how's it going guys matt here with go
tech tutorials today we're going to be
looking at another programming design
pattern and this one is going going to
be the composite uh structure so
yeah buckle up actually this one's quite
simple it's just a little bit of
wrapping your head around what you
actually want to do now the easiest way
to think of a composite at least for me
is a folder and a file structure on a
computer is almost the exact same thing
so essentially with a composite it's a
structure where you can have things
within things and it's often used
in that regard so
as far as files go the way they do it is
you have folders and within folders you
can have either more folders or files
that are kind of a dead end like they're
an executable or an image or something
you can't store more files within those
so that's the way to think of it is just
think of a file structure so there's
essentially two different main types of
files there's one that can host more
files which would be like a folder and
there's also a type that is just some
other object now you can apply this any
way you want you see this in a lot of
programs generally anytime you see some
sort of file structure looking thing
that's a composite and if you see
something that you want to traverse
recursively it's often a composite
because you can imagine from a client
end what you can do is you can just uh
you know you can pick an area and kind
of run through it so you can run
operations on these you can add remove
delete stuff like that and i'm going to
give you some root code and a few
examples and we'll go from there of
course we're going to be programming in
c plus and we're going to be adding to
our design patterns repo up on github if
you really like this series consider
giving it a like and all that good stuff
it does help a lot as far as continuing
making these a lot more goes into making
this than you think this has been
probably the third or fourth reshoot of
this at this point because i really want
it to be correct and i don't want a
whole bunch of confusing blunders in it
so these often take a lot of tries to
get right and hopefully i get this time
because i'm honestly getting tired of
re-recording this so the point is uh
leave a like if you would yeah thanks
and i just want to say in addition i
really appreciate the people that do
support me it does mean a lot i know
my videos aren't always the most
entertaining things on youtube but i'm
trying to provide some form of value
yeah i guess that's it let's let's dive
into some code and look at some more
composite examples for example if we
look at i don't know say blender you
know blender has the scene collection
over on the side for everything going on
in your scene this is essentially a
composite you've got these collections
which are basically folders and you can
have more objects within them and if you
want you can add more collections within
collections which are essentially the
folders and
you can kind of go from there so
this is one example of deposit you see
in literally every program that has this
sort of hierarchy where you can kind of
make collections of things it's
basically just a composite structure and
sometimes you have this for objects
within maybe a game or something i
believe animations use this sort of
structure for like bones and stuff like
that
so it's just used like crazy and i
encourage you to seek out other examples
don't think that this is the only
example on the internet look for other
good ones out there there's quite a few
uh so many that's almost confusing to be
honest so i'm trying to keep it
simplified in this so that when you look
at other examples online you can make
your own judgment of whether you think
that's a good or a bad example or
whether it helps or doesn't help but
essentially you just got to think of it
like a folder structure at least that's
my best
way of explaining it in a simplified
manner is in a way that everybody kind
of already knows
so we are here in our project um
right here design patterns we'll see
make projects up on github link below if
you want to check it out or whatever you
want to do it's fine we've added a new
composite folder in our design patterns
folder put the cmake in there to have
all that ready added it to the
level above it and we got a main and a
composite.h it's actually ready to build
right now it just doesn't do anything so
let's make a little example of how this
structure might start uh so first of all
you're going to need some kind of root
class that everything recognizes because
one of the other
things that i haven't really mentioned
yet is uh well i guess you can imagine
from the folder structure basically
everything's a file of some sort
okay so you can imagine if everything's
a file there's some base
there's a base class that basically says
everything's a file now people don't
often call it file usually they have
i don't know they call it like component
and composite generally or something
like that but it might vary but i think
for uh
simplicity's sake we'll call it
yeah we'll just make the root one file
now there's a lot of different ways of
doing this so this isn't necessarily
going to be the only way we're going to
be doing like a pure virtual way or an
abstract interface type style but you
don't necessarily have to make it
abstract but essentially you want your
root class to be all the base support
that a
a folder or composite
would have
but also
what a file
might have so
you don't necessarily want to put the
list of children in this one because you
don't know if it's a folder it's got to
be the folder type or the composite type
so if you look up the definition of
composite that'll make it make more
sense because it's essentially a
collection of things which is what a
folder is includes a collection of
things so
um yeah we'll call this file and let's
add some base functionality
void virtual void
uh let's just put an ad in here and add
is going to take a file pointer so you
can add another file
um but we're going to define well this
is optional how you do this is a couple
different different ways you can force
it to be overridden of course by putting
an equal zero here and that way they
have to define add to do something or
sometimes people put the root one to
essentially do nothing if it's not
defined so you have some files that you
just can't add to if you try to add to
it it will just do nothing
but that's kind of up to you i think in
our case uh well another thing you see
here
what i've seen in a few examples is all
the base
examples will throw some sort of
exception if they're not implemented
further down so we could even do that we
could make these throw exceptions but
the world is your burrito you do what
you want
there are some options for you i think
we're just going to go with the the
interface method and do this on a bunch
of them so we're going to have an ad
we're going to have like a remove or i
guess it would be delete cell
there's so many different options here
actually but that's kind of the standard
or add and remove uh you at least want
those
to be defined somehow
so say you got those and then protected
uh
i guess we don't really have anything
like this is probably good enough to
start you of course you want to cater
this to your example uh for what you're
working with in your project so it might
be a little different
and you might not even use this pure
virtual you might just start finding the
base type and then make some other ones
all right so let's make a folder so
class
folder or maybe we'll call this uh
i don't know it's just base a folder
which um
includes file
or inherits from file and then we can
just override these
void add
file override
so that's one
i think of a better name for file here
because you know i guess file is both
types right so that works as a base
class but this is essentially just our
base
file
we just want it for polymorphism sake we
want to be able to call the folder or
our objects a file that way we can pass
in either a holding folder or we can
pass in a unique object so of course
computers have a lot of different
objects there's images videos you know
media files like that and there's also
executables um so just depends what
you're handling as far as the stuff
you're putting in your component
structure or your composite structure
that
you want to support here so you'll have
to adapt it particular example as usual
but uh here we go so if it's a folder
let's make sure we get these right this
is going to be public
but
in a protected space we are going to
want
um you can go with other data types but
list seems to be the common you can go
list of file pointers
um and this will be the all the children
so there's kind of different ways of
doing this we got to be sure to include
list here
because you see some people also
they'll put in something for each of
these
basically like a parent so they'll have
like a file
pointer of parent and that'll generally
be what folder it's in
and and if it's null then you know it's
the most root one
so there's stuff like that you can do
too um it's kind of optional depends how
you want to design a lot of examples
you'll see parent and you'll see ways of
setting the parent but if you're just
for every folder you have a list of
children you can still traverse through
that but it's up to you whether or not
you want your children to have a pointer
back to the parent if it's relevant if
you need it for your code to traverse
that direction then do it if not then
well it's up to you so there's a little
bit of play here you could probably look
at big real world examples somewhere
like i don't know there's probably some
open source file management projects
that have some some deep code like this
that would be pretty interesting to look
at but uh for sake of time we're not
gonna be going into those but i think
i've probably said enough words for you
to kind of understand the gist of this
at this point on uh let's just finish
coding up our example at this point
another big consideration here as you
can see we're passing in just pointers
so
as you probably know if your c plus plus
coder if you're passing around pointers
you need to decide what is actually
happening with the data because sure
you're passing a pointer to a file but
you don't actually know what is
controlling the memory of that file so
something else could delete it in that
case what do you want to do
you probably need to check for null and
that sort of thing but uh that just
depends on your example because uh you
know you might do a file check or clean
up at some point anything that's null or
anything that has null point
appearance you might want to delete but
that's that once again up to your
implementation because who knows what
you're doing with your component
structure but you often see this worked
in with other stuff to kind of save
memory where you have like links so some
files are literally just links to other
files and that way you don't have two
copies of the same file rather you just
point to the same file somewhere else
but you can have it in multiple
structures and they all you know
reference type setup
so if you add a file in its most base
mode what you would do is just do a push
back
of the file so now this file that
currently could be another folder we
know it can't actually beat this because
this is pure virtual can't be
instantiated but we want to add more
types
let's call this
base
component i think
yeah let's go with base component but i
you know i think i think file is kind of
easier to understand as a word but base
component just for the sake of
inheriting because we actually want to
make other file types
so this would be
i guess let's think about this here
let's maybe have a media file
and have that inherit from base
component you know i guess i guess files
fine afterwards sorry for the confusion
but i think we'll just specify special
types of files instead so i'm going to
rename all these back to file click
rename feature suite
all right so that way you know we got
media file here and it's gonna
it's gonna be the same thing we just
need to
put these in here as well so the
remove's a little trickier you gotta
decide how you're gonna do the remove
obviously we don't have if it's a media
file you can't have any children under
that so that makes no sense so
this one we would just
actually
well we have to override it as something
but we could basically just do nothing
because if you try to put another file
inside this one it's just going to do
nothing right that would be fine or you
could throw exception whatever is best
for your code
do nothing in this case you can't host
more files
yeah sure because there's no list of
children so it would have to be a folder
file type to do that so hope that makes
sense the remove uh kind of jumping
around a little bit going back to the
folder the remove yeah obviously you'd
uh just do some functionality where you
check if this file is in your list and
if it is you remove it or you could even
do something like uh let's let's see
here
so this gets this could get a little
tricky because what if you delete a
folder what happens well in theory it
deletes everything within the folder
right or what happens if you move a
folder to another folder it moves
everything so that would actually be
fine because if you move this folder
it's going to still have its list of
children so that actually would work
fine but removing it gets a little
trickier because well here you can
remove the uh file itself so this might
just remove it from the children but if
you're calling
uh you know there's there's just
different ways of doing this i guess
maybe you actually want like a delete
here too like a virtual
void delete itself or something like
that
or no you want i guess you wouldn't even
need this um the delete self doesn't
really make a lot of sense but
basically you might need more support
than just plain old ad removed because
that's that's not always clear what's
going on but essentially you would if
you're
bringing it you're pointing to a certain
file to remove
i guess you could have the folder take
care of it or you could go in here
and uh do something here yeah i don't
know if this actually works too well um
this whole remove setup for how we're
doing it it's probably done in a better
way quite frankly so if you can think of
that you're welcome to edit this and
update it but you probably get the point
here
so i think in general this if we're
calling remove from a folder and we're
pointing to a certain file we probably
want to find the match here and then
delete that and we could do that by the
dereferenced pointer address because it
should match
however you probably only want to delete
the reference not necessarily the real
thing because if the real thing is in
other places then maybe you're just
deleting like a shortcut or something so
a lot of like little considerations
there for file type structures but uh
you're you know if you know exactly how
your data is supposed to work this
should all just kind of
come together as you're building it as
you do what you need to do with the data
and and provide the options you need
with your particular component structure
all right so what would remove do all
right let's let's go through this i
guess we go
you know i'm not going to do all this
code you'd probably do enough some sort
of erase if and and just remove it if uh
remove
matching file from list of children
so that would just be something to do
but since this is kind of a
not real example in just a sample
not real example just a sample that's
confusing um then
we don't necessarily know the best way
of implementing this yet so i guess
we're just going to leave it as is so
we got media file here
and you know maybe
we even have stuff like you can add
functionality in these so for example
this folder you might add some special
stuff here that is only
only the folder supports
but uh
yeah i guess there's a little
differentiation here because the folder
you can push back more files we try to
do it on these media files it's just
going to do nothing if
you call remove on a file then what's
going to happen honestly this doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense it'd
probably make more sense to have it some
kind of
set parent to null or something like
that so i guess if it's a media file
you'd have some sort of parent or maybe
they all have some sort of parent i
don't know it's a lot of theoretical
stuff here that you can get into very
quickly once you start designing it so
you really got to think about your
design and i could be here for a really
long time doing that and coming up with
little conceptual things but i'm going
to spare you and we're going to look at
a few more online examples and see how
they do and see if we can take any more
lessons because that's pretty much going
to be the episode here i'll say
doesn't really work
this case
need different
methods because apparently based on this
structure you call remove on the folder
so maybe you do that
but you can see from this media file
there's nothing pointing the folder so
maybe in this case we do want to go
and have the parent which is just going
to be a
file pointer well we know it's got to be
a folder at this point so we could even
make it just straight up a folder right
here
that way that you don't cast it to some
a legal other parent it's literally only
folders but it's going to be different
for you
and we'll just say parent folder
because then what we could do on this
remove is we could go parent folder
remove
the file so that would essentially go to
the parent and call the same thing and
uh it would do something like that now
this isn't necessarily good this might
be a little wonky so
but you need to make sure you set this
parent folder because it's going to be
null
so and that's another thing like when
you do this pushback file you could also
go children dot back the one so it's
literally the one you just pushed back
um
you would probably want to do like a set
parent so we could do that maybe we'll
just make a a method for it void
set parent
and this is also going to take a file
um
i guess we could define it no actually
we can't define it right because uh this
yeah this should i guess the parent
i'll get to the example shortly i guess
this parent should be here if you think
about it
uh and i guess at this point we'd have
to pull it called that
uh or maybe
yeah yeah i don't know i'm kind of
deciding here i guess we probably want
this virtual so you can play around a
few things and kind of get to get
whatever works best for you
is uh what this is going to come to like
i've kind of said multiple times but
yeah maybe we don't do that after all
maybe we literally put that in all the
media files because there's going to be
other types too just media but uh you
probably want to sort this somewhere if
you're if you've got support to go up
and down your hierarchy you've got a
program then it of course and it's
really simple that
and of course i forgot to put the
destructor here
at the top
of the default
but of course the destructor on the
folder you might probably want to remove
all the children so
well
it's all a bunch of file pointers so
this might be this might be a great case
for shared pointers because
sharepoint keeps track of how many are
being used and it would simplify these a
lot because as you remove them it would
kind of auto keep track of how many are
out there and once it's zero then it
would really delete the file so that way
you can have as many copies as you want
with less pain
to the programmer so great case for
these files to be shared pointers in my
opinion of all sorts so
i guess just keep that in mind and maybe
that's an improvement you want to make
but anyway let's move back over to where
we're adding to the folder
and we add a file to the folder we would
basically say
set parent
um
but here's the problem with set parent
we don't actually have it right i guess
we would have to put it in this root one
if we're going to call it here
yeah yeah we would
all right so i'll do it after all i'll
just go protected
um
we'll just take this
parent folder here
put it there
and uh yeah we'll add that set parent
method however this set parent method
it's going to have a default
instantiation here
and it'll just be parent folder
equals
file
so you can see
very quickly here oh this should be file
because this doesn't even know what
folder is yet so you can see there's a
little bit of a problem here because
by default if you don't override this
it's just going to allow you to set the
parent as a
potentially a file so it's not
necessarily going to be a folder so what
you probably actually want to do here is
uh
is make sure this is over written
in all these other ones like this folder
and media file um
yeah
yeah i guess that would that would be it
but uh to keep it super simple here
we'll just we'll just do it like this so
it's parent is literally going to be
this urn folder so we just go this
and that should work because it's a
pointer to the class and this class is a
file so it would allow you to do that so
set parent to this
so uh the the problem here it becomes
though you can call set parent from any
of these so maybe we don't even allow it
maybe we put this protected as well and
what this does is it no longer lets you
call set parents so easily
but
we don't necessarily want to pure
virtual because if they don't want to
override it they don't override but now
you can't call here so i guess that
doesn't work so well
but you could still do like a a friend
class setup and give it access that way
but that's going to get confusing
so i guess maybe in this case we throw
an exception so that'd be fine bro
not implemented or something i don't
know i'll just throw a negative one
that's fine sure whatever so if we try
to set parent and it's not instantiated
then it's not going to work so we want
to we want to override that here void
set parent
file
star file override
and this is where we could do it we
could go
i guess it would
all
be
now i'm confusing myself with this whole
example so it's kind of set parent make
it this uh over right here
yeah so we just go
let's see we're calling this on the
child so maybe we don't want that here
yeah okay this would be fine we would
have to do it like this actually we'd
overwrite it here i think this works
maybe we'd want it but i don't know you
decide
but essentially here
the children this child file should
override set parent
and if it doesn't then we're in a whole
world of pain but this could be a folder
too so the folder should also override
it so yeah they should it's maybe going
to be a little different depending on i
guess
it's the point here and i'm i'm kind of
getting a little confusing with this
example maybe so
yeah i am going to uh implement this and
then move on
so now yeah i think what we want to do
here is make sure the file we're setting
the parent as would have to be a folder
in this particular case so maybe we just
checked that so we do that with a cast
we could just go like uh
let's see holder pointer
um past check equals
dynamic cast
and folder pointer whatever this file is
and if
cash check
that's true then we know it's and we
know what it is
and we can set it
and if this fails then we know that this
doesn't work so we just skip over
because you can't set the parent as
another media file for example it has to
be a folder so you can set up a lot of
little stuff like that for traversing is
the main point all right let's take a
look at some examples shall we all right
you know just doing a google search for
composite and c plus examples uh there's
quite a few examples um i thought some
of them were not very good but i think
one of the better ones was this
refactoring.guru one it seems pretty
good
as far as the examples online go at
least compared to the others i thought
this was the superior one so i highly
recommend having a read of this having a
look through this code and maybe walking
through it see if you can understand it
actually let's just walk through it now
and uh see if we can understand i don't
know if i can collapse one of these
sides but i appreciate you guys i'm
refactoring dog guru
for the example you can see what they've
got included here they've got their base
component which does have a parent
component protected and then they've got
some comments to talk about things but
here they have some virtual stuff they
have the whole set parent method they
have the get parent method
um so that might be handy and they've
got add and remove
base instantiations here
they're not doing pure virtual so their
component is not pure virtual in this
case it just does nothing if you don't
instantiate these
so
that's just a different design and they
have they have something here uh is
composite as false so this would
basically be in our case would be like
the is folder so by default they're
saying no it's not a folder so this just
would be some file type or something
along that line along that line or maybe
an object in your structure
and then of course this the most
important thing there's there's
operations like i didn't put that in my
code but obviously these do something
when you double click them or say run or
whatever open so there's always going to
be some sort of operation uh if you're
using this component structure for like
graphic layers then the operation is off
to draw or something like that so
this is now a pure virtual class because
they set this equal to zero so you do
have to define your components it looks
like they give you some base
uh
base definitions that in case you don't
override you least have to override your
operation so they do leaf classes as
leaves as in the files not folders i
hope to make sense and you can see they
overrode this operation it just returns
leaf it's whatever that's their example
they're returning strings but normally
you would do something different
yeah i don't know depends on your
program but you can see they overrode
what they had to they left everything
else default and here we have a
composite or this would be the folder or
thing that holds a bunch of components
so you can see protected they have the
list of components all the children that
are in this composite they've got an ad
with the uh the push back and uh set
parent so that's cool they've got to
remove that they overrode a similar
thing they set the parent to null after
removing this remove component
um
calls another special remove function i
don't know if they've defined that
somewhere
but uh
i don't think it's in the default one
yeah because this is removed with a
capital r
so maybe they have this defined
somewhere else for a special remove
operation because it's got to check if
it's you know it's got to do a little
matching check to make sure it's
removing the component that they passed
in so a little kind of a weird thing but
i guess it could work and you can see
this for his composite they overwrote
that to say true for this so
um
i guess we'll get to that and they have
a whole operation here looks like it
just makes a little string and pluses
some stuff i think it looks at all the
children yeah just puts all the children
in a big list so now as a client code
they have some examples here for how you
might handle this on on your end once
you're programming your design or once
you're using your design so they have
this thing that takes uh one component
and just does its operation
they have uh this other code they put in
so they actually put like a bit of a
facade here which is interesting in
front of it with these client codes or
not necessarily sods but
basically they're putting another front
end on this so you can see here that
there's another example of a function
where they take two different components
and they check if the first one's
composite and if it is they add
secondary to it so this would probably
be like a just like a helper function
and then they have a main to to go
through and and do everything so i
thought this was one of the better
examples online so between all of that
i'm going to go ahead and push all this
code hope you guys have a better
understanding of what a component is how
to use it don't forget to leave a like
appreciate you guys we appreciate all
the supporters the the members on
youtube the patrons and uh twitch subs
and stuff like that you really do help
this keep going we got a lot more of
these to do so stick around all right
i'll see you next one man out peace
[Music]